j'ai un peu délinquante alors appelé pas
purement mais ça fermait minutes et
trotski c'est une femme plus grand que
nature
elle avait une personnalité absolument
flamboyante elle était aussi la femme
qui est rentré dans un bistrot puis que
là on tombe sur deux perdues qui est en
train de jouer aux machines à boules et
elle va voir de par dupuis lui papiers
de demandes d'entrevues et depardieu lui
dit oui dans les années 70 elle s'impose
comme une figure marquante du paysage
médiatique québécois elle qui était
originaire de nice vannes aujourd'hui a
choisi de se pencher cette fois ci sur
un sujet grave collaboratrice à la
populaire émission femmes d'aujourd'hui
pour laquelle elle a déjà remporté en
1974 le prix judith-jasmin nino petraeus
qui a réalisé des centaines de
reportages témoins privilégiés de ce
québec en plein bouillonnement comme
d'aujourd'hui n'a pas la prétention mon
père connaît plusieurs pétitions
passionnés qui plein de caractère ni
petrov qui mordait dans la vie c'est une
femme de passion de désir de plaisir de
fête et de cinéma évidemment
et oui elle avait un appétit de vivre
jusqu'à la fin j'aime les gens j'aime
tout ce pour différentes raisons
durant sa longue carrière et le couvert
le circuit des festivals de cinéma
internationaux et mener des entrevues
avec les plus grands noms du septième
art
les réalisateurs les comédiens et les
mails et koné seigle et pis je n'ai pas
les ailes et les chercher l'ellipse
chose que du zoo ton on allait pouvoir
on n'avait pas vu on connaissait pour
elle nous apporte toujours quelque chose
de nouveau quelque chose d'intéressant
en plus de sa carrière à l'écran et à la
radio et le publié quatre romans des
essais et des nouvelles
elle avait beaucoup peur qu'on m'oublie
et je le savais qu'on l'oublierait pas
qu'on veut tu oublié une femme comme
minou qui est vraiment hors normes
atypique une mère pas ordinaire les
archives de ces milliers d'entre eux vue
seront bientôt numérisés pour la
postérité par la cinémathèque et rendu
accessible au public et aux chercheurs
je suis
par par un film que je vois par une
chanson par un artiste jeu pour moi
c'est c'est ma respiration une ou
petrowski une vie digne d'un scénario
comme dans ses films qu'elle aimait tant
ici n'est dit alexandre chartier radio
canada montréal